START TONIGHT N, BOTH TEAMS
GO FOR  EKBLAD FEES
IT LINE  BARKOV  KESSEL THE CEN
FOR THEM.
22 OVER
COYOTES!
>> JUST TALKED ABOUT ALL THE
PUCK POSITION COCHETS OFF THE S
COYOTES HAVE BOUGHT EIGHT SHOTS
IN THIS  FRONT, GET
HIS FACE IS TURNED TO THE SIDE.
>> WE WILL LO-- GET IN
ES
EKBLAD,  HUBERDEAU  SCOOPS UP,
REINHARDT APPLIED.
ONE TIMER. S
ANYWHERE CLOSE TO THE SKATE
BLADE TO
HAPPY.
THEY SET UP AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT THE PLAYER IN A POSITION
TO SUCCEED.
>> A REAL GREAT MORE RELAXED.AN
INCREDIBLE D
SPENCER NIGHT, AND ARIZONA GETS
ONE BACK.
IF THE 4-2 GAME OPEN SIDE.
>>> A GREAT EXAMPLE IN THE
THIRD GAME NEVER OVERTHE BENCH.
ARIZONA AND THAT IS EMPTY 6 ON
5 ADVANTAGE FROM TOWAY BACK
MIMI
HUGE SAVE BY SPENCER NIGHT
PRESSURED BY